the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi our lesson today is concerned with
introducing a new type of integral when
we deal with calculus of several
variables and this might at first glance
seem to be a rather touchy subject the
idea being that up until now we've
talked about multiple integration yet
you'll notice that the title of this
block of material is just called
integration and the reason for this is
that when we deal with several variables
there is more than one type of integral
and what I would like to do is to
motivate today's lesson in terms of a
physical example and then come back and
talk about in more detail what happened
and why there is more than one type of
integral in the calculus of several
variables I call today's lesson
introduction to the line-to-line
integrals and to visualize how this
topic may be introduced consider the
following situation I have a force F say
define throughout the xy-plane here I
have two fixed points which I'll call p0
and p1 and I pick a particular curve
which joins p0 to p1 and the question
that I would like to solve is what is
the work done if I move a particle from
p0 to p1 along the curve C by means of
the force F and the reason this is
called a line integral is that somehow
or other you see I am going to be
dealing with the line or the curve C let
me assume for the sake of argument that
I know the equation of C in parametric
form let's assume simply that C is given
by X or some function of T and Y is some
function of T and since I'm going from
p0 to p1 T is defined on a specific
closed interval say T goes from t0 to t1
or if I want to write the equation of C
in vector form remember in vector form
the I component is X or at least in
Cartesian coordinate vector form the Y
component is X the J component is y so I
can write the same equation that the
curve is R of T where R is X of T I plus
y of T J as long as I'm using Cartesian
coordinates
here let me assume that my force is also
given specifically in terms of Cartesian
coordinates its M I + NJ where m and n
are specific functions of x and y and
just to review briefly the problem I
want to find the work done in moving
from p0 to p1 along C under the
influence of F now you see the thing is
we already know how to solve work
problems if the distance takes place
along if the displacement takes place
along a straight line so what we do is
the following we take the curve C and we
subdivide it into increments we break
the thing up what we do is is we look at
the case increment and join the two
endpoints of that increment by a
straight line a vector which we'll call
Delta R sub K we pick a point on the
curve in this interval and compute the F
after all we know the force as a
function of x and y but we compute that
force for that fixed point we then dot
that force with this displacement and
that is what that's the work that's done
if the particle had moved along the
straight line connecting these two
points under the constant force f of X
sub K comma Y sub K star and then what
we do is to find the approximation we
add up all of these forces all of these
works over the various increments notice
that you're doing two things in these
increments you first of all picking
small enough segments so that you can
assume that the straight line
approximation is a good approximation to
the curve and secondly small enough
segments that you are assuming that the
force at a given point is a good
approximation to the force along the
entire increment at any rate what we
then do as is we sum these up over all
the increments and by the way notice
that even though F is a function of x
and y along the curve C X and y are
functions of T and to emphasize this let
me rewrite this
simply by dividing and multiplying by
delta T sub K to indicate that if I now
put this remaining part of the
expression in braces what's in here is
really some function of T alone
in other words notice that this comes
very close to being how we define the
ordinary definite integral when we want
to add things up you see T is a scalar
and that the braced expression here is a
function of T alone it's a dot product
obtained this way at any rate what we're
saying now quite simply from a physical
point of view is to find the actual work
why don't we define the work to simply
be the limit of W sub n as the maximum
Delta R sub K approaches zero which is
equivalent to saying what find this
limit as delta T sub K the maximum delta
T sub K approaches zero and the point is
that this was the ordinary definite
integral remember how we wrote this you
replace the sum by the integral sign we
assume that T goes from some value t0 to
t1 those become our limits of
integration
every place we see the T sub K star we
replace it simply by T and every place
we see the deltas we replace those by DS
and we leave off the subscripts so and I
can't emphasize this pot strongly enough
in going from here to here we are using
nothing more than what happened in part
1 of our course namely this is the
definition of the definite integral that
we arrive at this expression here and to
show you other ways in which this is
written notice that F is mi plus NJ r is
X I plus y J so the I DT is the X DT i
plus dy/dt J and so if we then
mechanically just took the dot product
here notice that the integrand would be
M DX T plus n dy T times DT the
conventional shortcut for writing this
is to cancel DT from numerator and
denominator and this becomes the
standard no
for the line integral M DX plus n dy
along the curve C where C joins p0 to p1
and as I mentioned in a few minutes it's
crucial that we specify both the curve
and the points being joined and the
physicists usually abbreviates this by
coming back to the original notation
here and when he takes the limit he just
writes this as f dot dr and what I'm
saying is that this this and this are
simply different ways of writing this
expression here okay so this is how this
is then evaluated and I'm what I'm going
to do very shortly is specifically solve
problems using concrete values for F and
p0 and p1 but for the time being I would
like to make a little note here to have
you see what's happening and that's the
following notice that double integrals
are concerned with regions in other
words we use double integrals to find
area mass etc line integrals are
concerned with curves or boundaries of
regions in other words paths that
connect to points see in other words
somehow or other the double integral is
associated with area the line integral
with length and the point is that in 1
dimensional space the two concepts
coincide in fact we don't even talk
about area in one dimension unless by
area we meant one dimensional area or
length in other words both arc length
and area in the typical definition sense
of area the one dimensional area
coincide in one dimensional space in two
dimensional space they are quite
different in fact in a nutshell to see
what's happening essentially double
integrals are concerned with what's
going on inside a region R whereas the
line integral somehow or other is
concerned with what's happening as you
move along the boundary of the region R
and we'll talk about that in more detail
later in this lecture and this will also
be the topic of discussion in our next
lecture but for the essentially for the
remainder of this lesson let's take a
specific application of our earlier
physical remarks in the following
examples let's fix the points p0 and p1
to
to the point 0 0 & 1 1 respectively and
let the force mi + NJ be specifically y
squid I plus X squared J in other words
to compute the force at any point X
comma Y in the plane the I component of
the force is just the square of the y
coordinate the J component is just the
square of the x coordinate of the point
at which we're computing the force now
what we're going to do in the next three
examples is simply compute the work done
along three different curves that join
the point p0 to p1 and the work done as
a particle moves from p0 to p1 under the
influence of this specific force and as
I say just the curves that join p0 and
p1 will be different in the first
example the curve C 1 is simply the
straight line that joins 0 0 to 1 1 in
parametric form that would be x equals y
equals T where T goes from 0 to 1
noticing that when T is 0 you see x and
y are both 0 so we're at the point zero
zero and when T is 1 x and y are both 1
so we're at the point 1 comma 1 and if
we want to write that in vector form
remembering that the I component is just
X and the J component Y since x and y
are both T the curve has the form R
equals TI plus TJ the work done writing
it symbolically as we would in the
physical notation integral along c1 f
dot dr means what it's we dot F with the
R DT and multiply that by DT and
integrate that from 0 to 1 that's what
that infinite sum means notice in this
particular case F which is y squared
plus x squared since x and y are both
equal to T F is just T squared I plus T
squared J since R is TI plus TJ dr/dt is
just I plus J and consequently the
infinite sum that we want to evaluate is
just the double integral from sure it's
just the integral from 0 to 1
see just taking the dot product here T
squared plus T squared is 2t squared
integral from 0 to 1/2 T squared DT and
using the fundamental theorem of
integral calculus for a single variable
this is simply evaluated by this being T
cubed from 0 to 1
2/3 T cubed from 0 to 1 this is just 2/3
in other words sum you see what's hidden
here is the fact that when we write the
definite integral see this was a
function of two variables in here but
along the curve they have functions just
of the parameter T this is an ordinary
integrand which means we can either
think of it as an infinite sum or the
antiderivative evaluated in a specific
way don't lose track of the fact that
the work is still being defined as a
limit but we can compute compute quite
conveniently in terms of the fundamental
theorem of integral calculus at any rate
the work done then in example 1 as we
move from p0 to p1 under the force F
along this curve C 1 is just 2/3 now
what we're going to do is redo the same
problem only now we are going to choose
a different path which connects 0 0 to 1
1 in fact I will choose the parabola y
equals x squared and I'll write it
parametrically this way I'll let X equal
T YB t squared C so that says y equals x
squared and to get the point 0 0 T must
be 0 to get the point 1 1 T must be 1 so
again T varies from 0 to 1 continuously
or again in vector form the equation of
the curve C 2 is just what TI + T
squared J at any rate the work done by
definition symbolically is the line
integral along c - f dot dr
that still means f dot dr dt dt as t
goes from 0 to 1 in this case X is T and
Y is T squared so if we come back to our
definition of f and replace x by T and Y
by T squared we see that our force is T
to the fourth i + T squared J since R is
TI + T Square J the
rdt is just AI plus to TJ
remember we differentiate vectors
component by component therefore the
integrand is simply this dot product
which turns out to be what t to the
fourth times one plus T squared times
two T or T to the fourth plus T two T
cubed we now again use the fundamental
theorem evaluate this integral by the
antiderivative in other words this is
150 to the fifth plus one-half T to the
fourth evaluated between 0 and 1 and
that answer is 7/10 in fact this I guess
in a way was a bad problem from a
physical point of view an excellent
problem from a mathematical point of
view you see certainly from a physical
point of view 7/10 looks enough like 2/3
so the change isn't that drastic you
could almost call that an experimental
error but since we weren't doing an
experiment here and we're working with
exact numbers the fact does remain that
what 2/3 and 7/10 are different and if
nothing else what we've proven is what
that the work done as we move from two
fixed points p 0 from the fixed point p
0 to the fixed point p 1 under the
influence of a given force F actually
does depend on the path that we follow
you see we use two different paths and
got two different answers in other words
the line integral M DX plus n dy along
the curve C which joins two fixed points
p0 and p1 depends on C as well as on p0
and p1 and that's an important point to
keep track of we're going to mention
this in more detail as the course goes
along let me at any rate though let that
point remain fixed in abeyance for a
while and we'll go on with our next
example and for the next example what
I'm going to do is pick the same path as
an example to only in a different
parametric form you see I'm now going to
write C another way of writing the
parabola y equals x squared is to let X
equal T squared and y be T to the fourth
you see in that case Y is still equal to
x squared and to connect 0 0 to 1 1 T
still goes
zero to one so the work done along the
curve C three is given by this
particular symbol to evaluate this
remember now X is T squared so x squared
will be T to the fourth Y is T to the
fourth so Y squared will be T to the
eighth remembering that our force is y
squared I plus x squared J written in
two tuples notation our forces T to the
eighth comma T to the fourth our dr/dt
vector our dr/dt vector is what it has
components to t and for T cubed and
we're going to multiply that by DT and
integrate that from 0 to 1 that's simply
2 T to the 9th plus 4 T to the 7th DT
from zero to 1 that's T to the 10th over
5 plus T to the eighth over 2 evaluated
between 0 and 1 and that's equal to 7/10
which agrees with this result by the way
that's not a proof all I've shown is is
that two parametric forms led to the
same amount of work but at any rate it
does seem to indicate then when you can
compute the work over along the curve
see that that work done seems to be
independent of the equation for C and
hopefully this should be the case
because we would be in terrible trouble
I guess is the best word to put this as
if it turned out that the work done in
moving along a specific curve joining
two points under a specific force
depended on the equation by which you
represented the curve but I simply
wanted to give you an example to show at
least that the mathematical definition
appears to be consistent in other words
along the curve C 1 we got a different
amount of work done than along the
curves C 2 or C 3 but C 2 and C 3 were
actually what the same curve given by
two different equations so at any rate
the work does seem to depend on the
curve but it seems to be independent on
of the equation by which the curve is
represented at any rate I think we're in
position now to start an overall some
Maree going right back to the very
trucks of the problem as to why line
integrals and multiple integrals exist
namely in particular in the case of one
independent variable the integral from A
to B f of X DX has two equivalent
interpretations and by equivalent I mean
numerically equivalent you get the same
answer they are not equivalent
philosophically I know this is one of
the reasons I have this hang-up about
trying to spell out the philosophy for
you in many cases you will say we're
interested more in the application than
in the theory as I may have said to you
before in fact on many different
occasions occasions the easy part of
mathematics in most cases is actually
applying the computational recipes the
validity of the recipes is what is
usually the difficult thing and the
biggest mistakes are not made by a
person using the right formula and
making an arithmetic mistake is that he
uses the wrong formula and doesn't make
an arithmetic mistake so I want this to
be very clear to you why a certain
problem exists in two variables that
didn't exist in one and the point is
what that conceptually there were two
different ways to interpret the meaning
of the symbol integral from A to B f of
X DX numerically they came out to be the
same but what were the two different
interpretations one was as the limit of
a particular infinite sum right that was
the definite integral notation the other
was we could visualize the interval from
A to B as being a curve that could be
written parametrically say as X is some
function of T where T goes from t0 to t1
and we then make the user will change
the variables the same change of
variables that we were talking about in
the previous lecture namely every place
we see X we replace it by X of T C and
then the correction factor is DX DT and
the new limits are from t0 to t1 in
other words we get what at the integral
from A to B f of X DX is the integral
from T 0 to t1 f of X of T DX DT times
DT again observing that this is a
modified function of T alone here so
that this is just a change of variable
type thing and what am I saying
that in the one-dimensional case the
case of one independent variable these
two concepts while different give rise
to the same numerical answer in two
space however notice that our first
interpretation as an infinite sum
translates into the double or multiple
integral I keep saying double because
we're dealing with two independent
variables
obviously by now I hope it's clear to
you that the results generalize to n
variables but the idea is what that the
first interpretation of the integral in
terms of two independent variables gives
rise to the multiple integral alright in
fact I think I have the yeah that's
right and the second interpretation
gives rise to this expression here
noticing again that if you have a
one-dimensional vector the dot product
is the ordinary product in other words f
of X DX is f of X dot DX if you want to
think of X as being a one-dimensional
vector but why is this interpretation
notice the change of variables again
that we think of the curve C as being
given by the equation R equals some
function of T as T goes from t0 to t1 so
the substitution is what this means the
particular definite integral in terms of
T as T goes from t0 to t1 f of our R of
T dotted with dr/dt
that again is what that again is some
scalar function of T you see times DT
that's what that second interpretation
says and that's of course what we mean
by this particular notation okay two
entirely different things but at any
rate now getting back to what we saw in
our examples the line integral see f of
RDR often depends on C but not on the
equation which represents C by the way
we're going to show a very interesting
thing in the next lecture as to when the
line integral will
tendency and when it won't but the next
lecture actually is more general than
just answering that question the next
lecture centers around this question is
there any interesting relationship
between line integrals and double
integrals you see in the case of one
independent variable there was a very
interesting relationship between line
integrals and so-called double integrals
or integrals of infinite sums namely
they were exactly the same thing you
couldn't tell them apart that's what we
meant in our summary when we said we had
two different interpretations of the
same numerical result now the question
is in two independent variables these
two concepts are different are they
related and if so how and that will be
the lecture of our the the body of our
next lecture
at any rate then until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate